[Music]
this picture of a tulip bulb costs more
than your car
this rock costs more than your house in
fact you could probably buy five houses
for the price of this virtual picture
anyone can download for free and i know
most of you are thinking right now
wow i don't even have a house but
homeless or not today we're gonna unpack
what the hell is going on with nfts
thanks for coming to the ted talk ladies
and gentlemen welcome to the 10 million
dollar studio i'm your host the
non-fungible detective and today we're
talking about why logan paul just spent
600 000
on a jpeg
of this and why that's idiotic but first
let's talk about nfts more broadly we're
going to start with the basic assumption
that most of you guys know what a
non-fungible token is if you don't
here's a wonderful video by johnny
harris wtf is an nft but basically nfts
are a technology that allows you to make
a digital asset like a song picture book
whatever they allow you to make it
unique to make it scarce so far this
technology has primarily been used in
the art world crypto punks pudgy
penguins whatever a beeple is
the industry has been going insane and
there's been an absolute run on the
market with prices exploding in a way
that frankly makes it seem like it's
never going to stop everyone seems to
want to get in on nfts especially the
famous projects like crypto punks even
visa couldn't resist the fomo they
recently threw their hat in the ring by
paying a hundred fifty thousand dollars
for this image which i copied just now
this has left many people suspicious
some of them dismissing all nfts sort of
as scams people are calling it the 21st
century tulip mania which is a callback
to a famous speculative bubble where
people started to pay insane prices for
tulip bulbs in the hopes that other
people would pay even higher prices and
so on until the bubble popped and it's
easy to make that comparison partly
because people are literally selling
nfts of tulips now because yes ladies
and gentlemen i showed it at the
beginning of the video but this is
completely real this is an nft
collection called the dutch tulip field
which is a callback to that exact
speculative bubble and they're like
self-aware of it and people are still
paying insane prices for these things
with this one selling for 57
000
for this picture which is the price
of a very nice car
look can you imagine like you're going
out to get a get a car but you come back
home with a jpeg because you're like i
thought it was a better investment
so i mean you can understand why a lot
of people see this as a scam so with
things like this succeeding it's hard to
blame people for being suspicious and i
think we should call these things out as
scams but this isn't what nfts are
actually about nfts aren't scams any
more than actual tulip bulbs are scams
it's only when people start acting
irrationally then it becomes a scam
because yeah there's no way a picture of
a
rock is worth millions of dollars but
this is sort of what's so annoying right
now about this new wave of influencers
who are making waves by announcing in
massive headlines that they just
purchased super expensive nfts like
logan paul quote just dropped 188 eth
623 thousand dollars on this one-of-one
bumblebee probably nothing and this is
the jpeg and his whole attitude and
approach is about flipping nfts for
profit and eventually making money and
the endless speculation on what's going
to be the next hyped-up nft and that's
where the scam is but there's this whole
other side to nfts that have hardly been
getting any press and i want to give you
that side of things too and that's nfts
from the normal artist and collector
perspective and that's a hundred percent
not a scam and this actually hits really
close to home because um
guys i don't know if you guys know this
but uh roll some of the b-roll guys as
coffeezilla i rely on digital artists
for what i do now i'm not going to get
into why
not here in the 10 million dollar studio
you understand but needless to say this
show wouldn't be possible without our
amazing digital artist ed who we
sometimes refer to as little pixar
instagram link down below but what i've
realized with working with him is that
most 21st century artists don't work on
canvases anymore they work on computers
and the great side of this is that you
can design amazing immersive 3d
environments like never before but the
downside is
well it's hard to get anyone to value
that and pay for it even though it can
be way more detailed and accurate than
any paintings from the 1600s that go for
millions it doesn't matter because
there's no scarcity i'm gonna play some
digital art from another guy named jonas
that i really like but artists like him
artists like ed who are insanely
talented they really have no way to sell
their products in the way they could
back in the day if they were painting
right selling canvases and so the
options for them are limited maybe they
have to go work for a studio or video
game company and they can't be an
independent artist like they might want
to be and this is where nfts come in for
the first time digital artists who don't
use a physical brush can now be properly
valued because they can make limited
copies of something and if they're
popular enough
and they have rarity and value to
collectors they'll get paid for it just
like you have physical art collectors
now you're going to have digital art
collectors and it's just opened up the
ability to make a living for these
people in a way that didn't exist before
and that is the amazing part of nfts so
ladies and gentlemen how do we merge
these two ideas the tulip mania that
some influencers are promoting but also
this new awesome way for artists to get
paid for their work now can we reconcile
it and should you buy an nft
um i would say this ladies and gentlemen
it's gonna be healthy for your wallet to
ignore people like logan paul that act
like this is a surefire way to make you
rich right if you weren't already the
type to go to galleries and look for
rare art pieces and flip them on the
weekend
in other words you're not an art dealer
why would you act like one now like
literally you have these people who've
never been interested in art in their
life suddenly acting like they're the
director of christie's like stop it okay
you're not instead i i don't know i
think it's pretty simple
i don't even know why i have to explain
this but like if you like digital art
you're inspired by it go find a piece
you like and then ask yourself if i
could never sell this would i still buy
it and if the answer is yes buy it so
there you go
nfts solved ladies and gentlemen not a
scam but being treated like a scam by
the broader internet community because
honestly there's nothing we can't mess
up you know what that's the truth give
us an amazing technology we'll price the
rock at a million dollars not that rock
this rock but anyways ladies and
gentlemen thank you for watching thank
you for coming to my ted talk if you
enjoyed it pump the stock it's free
ladies and gentlemen i appreciate you
and i will see you in the next one